hallo mein name ist luca heute bin ich
allerdings wieder sketche als meine
damen und herren wir befinden uns ja
heute im auto im pokémon mobil das ziel
heute wird sein dass wir zu einer
pokemon arena fall bzw einem pokémon jim
und versuchen werden diese arena ein
zunehmendes wissen ich bin team blau und
wir haben hier direkt nebenan das kann
wieso wieder überhaupt im aus hinter die
arena ist auf jeden fall vom team rot
eingenommen das heißt wir gucken einfach
mal ob wir die einnehmen bekämpfen
können keine ahnung ich habe so etwas
noch nie gemacht deswegen finden wir das
jetzt zusammen raus angeblich soll das
ganze hier seien wir uns einfach die
location gerade mal ge mehr aber ich
natürlich nicht mit dem handy gegen die
am steuer agieren will habe gerade
gesehen wir haben davon ein taxi
macht der fall wir sind jetzt hier
angekommen haben jetzt auch direkten
parkplatz gefunden jetzt kein mensch
also wenn es nicht schaffen diese arena
einzunehmen dann sind wir echt
unglaublich noch freuen
pokemon ja gerade angekommen gefahren
ist die arena
wir haben jetzt hier gerade in der
nebenstraße vorne die scheiße freunde
wegen behinderten pokémon gold eps
fehlern sie zu retten
wir haben jetzt hier vorne die arena
schmettert den ball einfach gut weg die
arena wird gerade gehalten von team gelb
und einem klo fans egal wer hält in der
arena mit einem fucking than some an
immer willkommen zuvor immer wenn ich in
pokémon video auf einem bild kommen
entweder irgendwelche trecker rasenmäher
lkw schulklassen in london oder hier
irgendwelche wir fangen jetzt an oh mein
gott was ich habe so was noch nie
gemacht macht irgendwas war hier waren
dann den anderen sehr tief und wir haben
potenzial sieht doch super das toll du
hast gewonnen
als ob das so schnell geht ich habe
gerade fucking arena eingenommen die
arena ist jetzt laut aussagen nur trage
ich kann jetzt hunden reingehen kann als
beispielsweise wenn man meinen doch nur
einsetzen deren ex-mann 36 wettkampf
punkte und jetzt habe ich die arena
eingenommen blazer tokio 12 hat diese
arena eingenommen
victoria hat youtube
ich dachte jetzt nicht braucht dafür
zehn jahres kampf oder hey aber
plötzlich geht man eigentlich ist das
nitro fans schon starkes pokemon da das
jetzt wirklich so schnell ging mit der
ersten arena weil ich irgendwie einer
der besten pokémon trainer der welt bin
getroffen
das jetzt so schnell ging und wir noch
eine andere arena hier gefunden haben
auch von team werden wir jetzt einfach
mal diese arena mit am start
die mutter aus
hier lebt nicht passt aufgefahren was
ungefähr haben davon einen zug hat was
jetzt aus dem auffangen werden
ich hab mich getroffen
20 wecken wir versuchen das rüber zu
fangen meine richtung schon wieder nicht
getroffen
wir versuchen das tier zu fangen was da
vorne immer noch unfertig ist angekommen
vielleicht kennen dennoch irgendwie
dieses schild oder diesem wald hier und
zwar sind wir wirklich genau da wo wir
genau hier waren wir schon in meinem
ersten pongau video was hier verlinkt
gegend wo da ist es verlinkt fast
täglich kann man gerade hoch genommen
hier ist die arena wir stehen direkt bei
den tauben oder keine ahnung was das
alter schwede was geht immer den kindern
darf alter ich will
denn ich bin was dazu ist unsere lautet
alter finde eine andere athletin des
pokémon 2
ich hab's das ist lockt an arena für
diese kinder und was sagt ihr verlauf
stop flug hat gerade den alten wander
fast umgerannt soll dadurch ein bisschen
piste schoss hast du den alten mann um
genannt es war vielleicht ein bisschen
vor den kindern hier weglaufen weil ich
in der arena noch kein pokémon firmen
eingesetzt hat deswegen nehmen wir die
arena jetzt erst mal noch ein was viele
mich verarschen fühle mich verarschen
von videos ich habe das gerade
eingenommen wann hast du eben nicht bis
er weggerannt
wir haben jetzt in diesem video heute
zwei arenen angegriffen haben auch
eingenommen die andere konnte ich das
leider nicht nur einen bereich
weggelaufen bin ich du [ __ ] wenn ihr
das nächste mal im nächsten video so was
sehen wollt wie das sich beispielsweise
mal wenn es dunkel ist irgendwie raus
gehen und dann vielleicht versuchen
arena einzunehmen last auf jeden fall
den daumen nach oben da schreibt mir
meine kommentare was ihr so für pokémon
hat bei mir ist das krasseste glaube ich
jetzt einen hypno mit gegen die 600
irgendwas oder so und dann will ich
sagen as catch in meine damen und herren
der beste sein ich kenne die sie gebaut
über beiden breit
ich dachte
europa